>>Ian: Hey there.
Welcome to another version of the Friday Review.
Now, we promised that we would do a sound
check today.
And instead, we totally got drunk.
So, let's do a sound check right now.
Reto, you should be seeing levels that are
about a half-inch below the red zone on the
audio meter.
Are you seeing anything?
It's too high.
>>Dan: Too high.
>>Ian: I'm too hot.
Again.
>>Dan: You speak loudly.
>>Ian: OK.
So, probably.
Well.
>>Dan: I almost jumped out of my seat.
>>Ian: What the hell?
>>Dan: Dude, I was like, I was like.
>>Ian: Oh, no.
I just did that to screw with you.
>>Dan: Oh, OK.
>>Ian: What?
OK.
Are we there now?
You should be adjusting the main volume, probably.
>>Male: Yeah, I was just gonna say, you should
be a little bit--.
>>Dan: Just if you had any question whether
or not this was actually live, you can tell
because we would never do this.
>>Ian: OK.
Great.
Oh, yeah.
Well, because we have a sign on behind us
saying, "On Air."
Come on.
Oh, what the hell?
>>Dan: Yeah, I know.
Exactly.
>>Ian: Aah.
Aah.
There we go.
>>Dan: All right.
That's the way it should be here.
>>Ian: Now we're on air.
>>Dan: That's right.
>>Ian: Can you guess?
So.
>>Dan: What to do when you have an extra zoom
lying around.
All right.
>>Ian: Welcome back to the Friday Review of
Games.
I, as always, am Ian Ni-Lewis.
>>Dan: I'm Dan Galpin, as the sign underneath
me says.
So.
>>Ian: And not as always, that came as a complete
surprise to me.
What the hell?
>>Dan: No.
>>Ian: All right.
So, today, we're drinking something reasonably
special.
This is something that I have no idea how
to pronounce.
Traquair, maybe?
>>Dan: Sounds good to me.
>>Ian: Traquir?
No.
It's certainly not that.
This is a handmade ale brewed in the ancient
brew house of the oldest inhabited house in
Scotland.
So, it's 1930 or something.
>>Dan: And according to a not particularly
reputable source, it is one of the, if not
the rarest beer in the world.
>>Ian: Actually, I think that reputable source
was a dude in San Jose, California.
Not Scottish.
>>Dan: Oh.
All right.
Sorry.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Nice hat, though.
>>Dan: Thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, I know this does not actually fit the
crazy hat standard that I've been setting
lately.
Oh, if you don't mind opening this for me,
I'd be honored.
>>Ian: Oh, sure.
>>Dan: All right.
So, today we have five games that we are looking
at.
All of these, fortunately, do run on our testbed
device here, which is, as always, the Transformer
Prime.
>>Ian: ASUS Transformer Prime.
HDMI Stand-by.
>>Dan: Exactly.
And yes, and that does, the cool thing about
it, is they have really cool HDMI features.
So, we like that and we're actually trying
to put this on the air for you guys.
And four of these were actually nominated
by you out there in the audience.
And we did throw in one additional one as
a wild card just 'cause I really like it.
>>Ian: But before we get to our games, we
need to talk a little bit about changes coming
to the Friday Review.
>>Dan: Am I gonna stop wearing hats?
>>Ian: No.
>>Dan: Oh, OK.
>>Ian: Although, I don't know what your hat
budget is, but it must be gargantuan.
>>Dan: It's almost as big as the beer budget,
but not quite.
>>Ian: You know I'm actually buying this beer
myself now.
>>Dan: Are you really?
>>Ian: Yeah.
If you wanna try to chip in, I stopped expensing
it because of, you know.
>>Dan: Oh, yeah.
OK.
>>Ian: Anyway.
>>Dan: Why?
No.
>>Ian: No, 'cause I--.
Anyway.
[Ian and Dan laugh]
We'll go into that later.
So, here's what we're doing.
Now, we've gotten a lot of comments asking,
"What is it about the votes?"
"Does the voting suck?"
Or, "Do you even look at what we vote for,
and if you do look at what we vote for, aren't
you being just biased by people who have a
lot of friends?"
Etc., etc.
>>Dan: That is true, actually.
Do game developers have lots of friends?
>>Ian: Apparently not.
>>Dan: OK.
>>Ian: Based on the number of votes people
are getting, no.
>>Dan: OK.
>>Ian: Developers have no friends at all.
Just wanted to verify.
I wanted to clear that up because most of
the game developers I know work a lot.
So, outside of their local team.
>>Ian: That's true.
>>Dan: I guess if they have a large team.
Anyways.
>>Ian: No, no, because they hate those other
guys.
They're always screwing them with the code.
>>Dan: Right.
Exactly.
>>Ian: Anyway.
Here's the deal.
We thought it would be a lot more interesting
if we broke things up a bit.
Instead of having one master list of everything
to vote for, we're going to actually have
a different list for every week.
And every week we're gonna pick a theme.
Now, next week's theme is tower defense games.
So, you know I'm gonna be playing this stuff.
I'm a huge tower defense fan.
>>Dan: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: After that, we have driving games.
And then, on August 10th, we're going to be
talking about Asian RPG's.
So, JRPGs, KRPGs, any, that stuff that you
used to play on your PSP, that's what we're
gonna talk about.
>>Dan: Yeah, nominate those really soon because
those take a while to get into.
And it'd be cool if we actually got a chance
to play them for more than a couple of hours.
So, lets.
>>Ian: So, if you go to the old moderator
link, you'll now see each of those categories
and all of them are open.
And you can vote on any of them, but the voting
closes the Wednesday before the Friday that
we're gonna review them.
So, next week on the 25th, you're going to
be, or until the 25th, you're gonna be able
to vote on the tower defense games you'd like
us to review on the 27th.
>>Dan: And, you know, this is a dangerous
week.
I think the other good thing about this is
that we've made this the shortest week, so
we'll be playing the least amount of time.
'Cause I tend to find that tower defense games
really do suck away all of my free time rather
impressively.
So.
>>Ian: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
If you watched the review last week, you know
that Radiant Defense basically became my life
for a great deal of June and May.
Yeah.
I'm finally, I finally kicked that habit,
but it took a while.
I had to go to Betty Ford for a bit.
Rehab.
>>Dan: Yes, exactly.
>>Ian: But we love tower defense games.
>>Dan: Now we can focus on our other bad habits,
so.
>>Ian: I think we're gonna nominate some games,
too.
I'm definitely gonna nominate Sentinel 3:
Tower Defense.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
Yeah, there are so many good games in this
category.
I'm tempted to actually give Guns and Glory
another look through.
>>Ian: Really?
Guns and Glory?
>>Dan: Not Guns and Glory.
Wait.
I'm blanking out.
I'll get into other games later.
So, all right, so.
Let's go actually to what we're gonna be doing
here today, which is looking at five games.
Now, I'm gonna start off by looking at Auralux.
And the reason why is because it's the first
in the order of icon stashed on the screen.
>>Ian: I think you went alphabetically.
>>Dan: I did, yeah.
That's true.
>>Ian: OK.
Well, this is your wild card choice, right?
>>Dan: This is my wild card choice.
I also, I just wanted to give you a call out.
The live wallpaper that is actually on the
screen is actually being generated by one
of our five games this week.
>>Ian: Oh, my goodness.
Really?
That's a good live wallpaper.
>>Dan: It's not bad.
>>Ian: You know, we keep telling people, "If
you want a great live wallpaper, you should
totally do an aquarium app because people
love aquarium live wallpaper.
But quite honestly, a lot of the aquarium
apps out there, they do live wallpaper.
They're not graphically impressive.
>>Dan: No, no.
This ends up--.
>>Ian: This one, yeah.
>>Dan: This ones got a nice puny fish.
But we'll talk about this later when we get
into looking at fish farms.
But let's talk about Auralux.
So, Auralux is a real-time strategy game.
>>Ian: I remember, now the developer showed
us this when?
When was it?
Was it at a conference or something?
>>Dan: It was a GDC.
Again, it was a few months ago.
And I looked at it and without actually having
a chance to play it, I was, "I know, it's
kinda cool looking."
But, of course, you actually start playing
it and you realize that it's actually very,
very cool.
And this is--, I like to consider this a preview
of what's to come because currently, the game
is only available on Tegra devices and only
available, I believe, only on tablets.
But he is rapidly adding, the developers,
rapidly adding more devices.
So, in the game, it plays fairly straight-forward.
It actually used a control scheme that if
you've played the game Osmos, you're familiar
with.
So, use two fingers in order to scroll around.
You can hit zoom and then I can actually go
and I can take individual ones of my little
guys, draw around them with a circle, and
I wanna send them on to somewhere else.
So, I'll send them to here.
Like that.
And we'll send us another.
>>Ian: They just go, like little mosquitoes.
>>Dan: Exactly.
Exactly.
>>Ian: OK, cool.
>>Dan: And what's cool about the game is--
>>Ian: There's a lot of them.
I think that's why they've restricted it to
certain number of devices, trying to make
sure that they've got the CP power to--.
>>Dan: And I can also send them into my own
star.
And this upgrades the power of that star.
The number of rings around the star actually
determines how upgradable it is.
>>Ian: So, you're like, sacrificing your dudes
for more power?
>>Dan: I would say that they're actually becoming
part of the fabric of the stars.
So, they're colonizing that star.
That's the way I look at it.
>>Ian: Sacrificing your dudes.
Just like some bosses.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
Not like our boss, though.
He would never do that.
>>Ian: No, not at all.
>>Dan: So, umm.
You sounded sincere when you said that.
So,--.
>>Ian: So, actually, no.
We should give a shout out to our boss, Billy
Rutledge, who earned an honorable mention
as Best Manager of the Year here at Google.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Why an honorable mention?
Because the man wouldn't let him get first
place.
>>Dan: I think the good news about it being
an honorable mention is that he gets some
acclaim, but he doesn't have to actually do
any work, like the people who actually forward
the award, like the people the award have.
So, but anyways.
A good shout out to him around that.
And so, this is the game.
One of the funny things about this game is
you can accelerate time, but you have to buy
it in the store, which I think is awesome.
>>Ian: Oh, that's an interesting strategy
for monetization.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: Yeah.
We talked a lot about monetization strategies
last week.
This isn't my favorite one.
And the reason is that I don't feel like I'm
getting a lot for--.
>>Dan: Do you want my money, Ian?
>>Ian: I think that, for me personally, I
like to buy things that I feel like they could
effort.
>>Dan: OK.
>>Ian: So, if the developer meant--.
Like, we talked about Radiant Defense and
their additional packs.
>>Dan: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: And those are simple things.
You can make an argument that those packs
should have been included with the original
game, but they contained extra units, extra
weapon types, extra animations, extra strategy.
All of these things took time to design, create,
program, and balance.
>>Dan: Mm-hmm.
>>Ian: So, I feel like I paid two bucks, three
bucks, five bucks for something that people
worked on.
When I'm buying time, I don't know.
It doesn't feel the same way.
I think there's a lot of people who will pay
for things like that.
And certainly, I'm one to talk 'cause I pumped
plenty of quarters into arcade machines in
my youth, but when you're buying something
that doesn't have an obvious labor associated
with it, you're definitely gonna be attracting
a different demographic.
>>Dan: Now, the other thing you can't really
tell--unfortunately, you can't play sound
here--but although, strangely enough, the
music in this game, a lot of it is creative
commons licensed, but--.
>>Ian: But try getting the man to understand
that.
>>Dan: Which man are we talking about here?
Not our boss, right?
>>Ian: No, no.
>>Dan: So, in any case, the, but actually,
a lot of these flashes and pulses in my world
is now getting completely obliterated.
>>Ian: What happened?
>>Dan: Yeah.
I just got attacked by the green guys.
I'm basically screwed.
The green guys and red guys are both gonna
go after my world now.
>>Ian: You sold the blue guys out is what
happened.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna get these
guys out of there because by getting them
out of there, they'll attack each other.
And so, that's another good strategy in the
game.
Now, so, the game actually plays music in
line with the pulses and there's actually
sort of a beat going on.
>>Ian: Oh, OK.
>>Dan: There's a synthesasia--.
>>Ian: Synesthesia.
>>Dan: Synesthesia, yeah, thing going on.
Thank you.
>>Ian: That's pretty cool.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, that's actually a fun part of the game
that unfortunately, you're missing out on.
So, that's an example of the kind of strategy
that one might use.
Unfortunately, I'm kind of weak to be using
any strategy right now.
The other thing I would want to point out
here is that the game actually does not do
a bunch of things correct with the back key.
And so, the developer already knows this 'cause
here, the back key--
>>Ian: Woah.
Dude, you're gone.
Did it take you back into the game?
>>Dan: I think I might've hit the home key
there.
What is cool about the game is that you have
a resume right here at the beginning.
>>Ian: OK.
That's nice, but you know, what's not nice?
It's that splash screen.
So basically, if I hit a button that I didn't
mean to hit, boom.
I gotta wait and watch your logo for about
15 seconds.
>>Dan: Well, no.
That's only when I relaunched it.
But admittedly, yeah.
The splash screen doesn't really--.
>>Ian: So show me.
Yeah.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, if I click home, and then I go back, it's
not, it's not--.
>>Ian: Oh, OK.
>>Dan: But admittedly, it doesn't need to
be there.
The game's already running.
It's already actually running in that other
case, potentially.
Although technically, if you hit the back
key to exit, it's the process you expect when
you go back into it, it's gonna do whatever
it does and start.
So, yeah, it's one of those things where it
sort of missed.
But you can certainly multitask quite effectively
with it.
And I love the fact they put a resume in there.
I mean, this is, this is exactly what I would
like to see.
It makes it very clear.
>>Ian: Yep.
That is very cool.
>>Dan: Look.
It's a game in progress.
It's right there on the front screen.
>>Ian: Hey, let me move this to the center.
>>Dan: Oh, yeah, yeah.
Sorry.
I don't wanna break the HDMI connection.
>>Ian: We'll break the HDMI connection.
>>Dan: OK.
>>Ian: It's weird.
We have better HDMI connection.
This show is brought to you by Doctor HDMI.
>>Dan: [laughs] That's right.
All right.
So, that's Auralux.
Again, there's a lot of really great stuff
in this game.
And I really enjoy playing it.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: So, it runs great on the Transformer
Prime.
So, we'll probably take another look at that
one when they actually get a build out maybe
for a minute or two on a future show.
>>Ian: We're excited about this.
It's good stuff.
Now, before we move to the next game, let
me just ask you, what do you think of this
beer?
>>Dan: Oh.
You know, it's funny.
I like it.
Yeah.
>>Ian: It's different.
>>Dan: It's different.
It didn't like, strike me as being, I don't
know.
It's good.
I mean, what's your opinion?
>>Ian: Maybe we should have Reto taste it.
He has an accent.
>>Dan: Oh, that's a good point.
>>Ian: Here you go, Reto.
Reto, why don't you introduce yourself to
the guys here?
You can picture-in-picture yourself now.
>>Reto: Can I?
Because I don't think you've set me up with
the thing.
>>Ian: No, you got the Hangout dealy-bobber?
>>Reto: It doesn't look like there's a Hangout
setup.
>>Dan: Oh.
>>Ian and Dan: No way.
>>Dan: Oh well.
>>Reto: I'm right online.
You can tune in an hour before these guys
have the app review, and I have an accent.
So, apparently that makes me best suited.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: I found that a British slash Australian
accent is absolutely best game review accent
in the world.
>>Reto: Really?
I thought it was the way you got onto House,
but I guess [ ].
>>Ian: That, too.
>>Dan: [laughs] Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: All right.
So, let's take a look at our next--.
>>Dan: Yeah.
I'm not gonna look at Crates on Deck because
Crates on Deck required, yes.
'Cause Crates on Deck requires rotating this.
Let's go to the ones that all work in landscape
first.
So, now we're gonna look at Drive with Zombies.
And Drive with Zombies is a perfect example
of a game that kind of works on tablets.
And what I mean is that a lot of the touch
areas are actually sized in a way that's really,
really appropriate.
>>Ian: No.
Hang on.
It's the Welcome app for Android.
That's our account, right?
>>Dan: Yeah.
Yes.
So, it actually uses account manager on this--.
>>Ian: That's so cool.
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: That's great.
>>Dan: So, yeah.
So now, we select our vehicle.
And the goal with this game is to avoid zombies.
You may not be able to tell by looking at
it, the graphics are low res and you actually,
the game--.
>>Ian: Well, they're not bad.
Well, the title screen I like, but yeah.
This one, it reminds me of Desert Bus.
>>Dan: Mm-hmm.
So, you've got some choices.
You can run over zombies now.
You see, there's a little icon there on the
side.
It wants me to shoot that zombie and try not
to--.
>>Ian: Oh.
>>Dan: And so, for the most part, the biggest
problem with this game is that it is probably
that it's looking at this device, this is
an MDPI device rather than as a tablet device.
>>Ian: Wait.
Really?
You think that's the problem?
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, these--.
>>Ian: Why do you think that's the problem?
>>Dan: 'Cause the resources are really small.
>>Ian: Oh, you're talking about the size,
like up in the left hand corner.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Exactly.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: So, my suspicion is that, you see how
small that little arrow is on the right?
So, my feeling is that on a phone, all this
would be fine.
I didn't have time to play this on a phone,
so I actually don't know.
So--.
>>Ian: I think the real problem with this
game is there's like this great concept, but
it could be ten times more awesome.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It just, it really--.
>>Ian: And I'll tell you, part of it would
be just actually going back and doing a demolition-style
version, like some crash physics.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: What's that game where you just have
to crash everything in an intersection?
We looked at it a while back.
>>Dan: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't remember, but I know.
>>Ian: Or that game for the Xbox 360.
Burnout.
Right?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Was it Burnout?
No.
I can't remember.
Anyway.
>>Reto: It was.
It was Burnout.
>>Ian: Ok.
>>Reto: PSP though.
>>Ian: Right.
Right.
Yeah.
>>Reto: Three or four of the intersection
crashes.
>>Ian: Exactly.
Yep.
And now, when I hit a bus there, I'd like
something to happen.
I'm just saying.
I think it would be cool.
>>Dan: Yeah.
And so you know, you'll see a lot of things
in this game are, a lot of the graphics are
just a little bit low resolution, which means
certainly low res for a Galaxy Nexus or a
lot of the devices that are out there.
So, that's just one more note about the game.
Also, you'll see that things like the numbers
aren't actually centered.
Like, if we actually take a look here.
I guess I don't have touch enabled.
>>Ian: See, I thought that was just avant
garde.
>>Dan: No, no, no.
It's actually, it's throughout the--.
>>Ian: DPI problem?
>>Dan: Yeah.
It's right throughout the entire app.
>>Ian: So, the main lesson here is test on
multiple devices.
And one of the reasons that we do this show
is because we're good friends with the people
that do game reviews for Google Play.
And here's a tip.
Google Play, the Google Play game review team,
the people that decide which games get featured
or not, care a lot.
Now, this may come as a surprise.
They care a lot about the Nexus 7.
Now what we're looking at here is essentially
identical to the Nexus 7.
It's a little bit different, but the hardware
and the screen resolution are pretty much
exactly the same.
The DPI's a little different.
If you're not working on this class of tablet,
it's very, very unlikely that you'll get featured.
And the reason is we, as Google and especially
the Google Play guys, care a lot about the
success of the Nexus 7.
We're super.
If you watched our show last week--
>>Dan: We care about all of our--.
>>Ian: you know that we're just insanely excited
about this.
But we care about all Android.
>>Dan: All of our Android children, really.
I mean,--.
>>Ian: But they have a special place in our
heart.
>>Dan: Yeah, absolutely.
Mostly 'cause it's really fun to game on.
>>Ian: Now, if you're on this tablet, if you
work on this, Asus Transformer Prime, Galaxy
Tab, all of those things, you have to work
on that class of device if you wanna be featured.
>>Dan: Sure.
Yeah.
I mean, I think everyone should make sure
their app looks good on a ten inch tablet,
a seven inch tablet, and a five inch phone,
unless there's some--a four to five inch phone--unless
there's some really, really strong reason
why your app doesn't make sense.
And even then, probably make it look good
anyways because even if it doesn't make sense,
someone's gonna want to play with it.
Even if your primary reason is doing hundred
mile an hour photography with the phone strapped
to your head, make it run on a tablet.
OK?
>>Ian: That would be awesome.
A tablet strapped to your head?
>>Dan: I know.
Exactly.
Not only that, it also works as a deflector.
So, in any case, it's like that iPad YouTube
video where she gives the iPad to the grandfather
and he uses it as a chopping block.
So, in any case, Drive with Zombies.
So mostly I wanna see higher resolution textures.
I wanna see the control just being a lot more
solid.
The control is, it feels like semi-analog,
but not really.
Like, you have to tilt it, then you get this
immediate woo.
And I really wanna have much tighter control
if I tilt it a little bit, I get a little
of accelerometer, rather than a jolt as if
I've now pushed the left arrow key.
That's sort of what it felt like when I was
playing the game.
>>Ian: Now, one tip that we get.
So, we actually had a really fun summit meeting
with a bunch of, all of the leading game engines
and hardware manufacturers, right before Google
I/O. And one of the things that came up was
the fact that very few games are correctly
using the gravity sensor.
Now, that's understandable because we've improved
it recently and it wasn't that good earlier,
but if you use the gravity sensor, A, it gives
you a quaternion.
See, now, it's fun because we're doing the
game review and I can say quaternion without
having to explain what it is.
>>Dan: I think you should explain it anyway.
>>Ian: OK.
Well, a quaternion is like a rotation matrix.
Good enough?
OK.
>>Dan: Good enough.
>>Ian: So, the thing is, it gives you back
a quaternion that you can plug directly into
your engine.
It's really precise, especially compared to
the other sensors.
It brings together all of the data from all
of the sensors on the device to try and distill
it in the most precise sensor you can get.
And not only is it precise, it reacts really
fast.
So, people that have used the gravity center,
and I think Vector Unit was there and they
switched over to the gravity sensor just a
couple days later.
And they're like, "Wow.
We can't believe how awesome it is to play
Rip Tide with this now that we've switched
over.
It just feels so much better."
>>Dan: And it was pretty awesome to play Rip
Tide in the beginning.
Let's just make that clear.
>>Ian: Oh, yeah.
It wasn't a bad game to begin with.
>>Dan: Rip Tide was great, but it made it
even better.
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Dan: In the gravity sensor.
>>Ian: You know what?
>>Dan: Yeah?
>>Ian: I've decided--
>>Ian: that I hate the bags under my eyes.
>>Dan: Oh, OK.
>>Ian: All right.
Now.
>>Dan: So.
That was good.
>>Ian: Excellent.
>>Dan: Now we need to make sure that one of
these ones with the sunglasses actually is
the one that's used for the preview frame
on YouTube.
'Cause that's just the way it should be.
All right.
>>Ian: All right.
>>Dan: Let's go to the next game.
So, the next game I wanted--
>>Reto: --cause if we combine the two of you,
we almost have a Blues Brother.
>>Dan: We actually need to come in wearing
Blues Brothers outfits at some point.
I think that would--.
>>Ian: I do have a Jake mask that I wore for
Halloween the other--.
>>Dan: I think just a suit with a hat would
work with the black tie.
So, in any case, all right.
So the next game I wanted to look at was Nosferatu.
Nosferatu is in the endless runner class.
And it says "Nosferatu, Run from the Sun."
And actually, the biggest problem with this
game is actually its market listing page,
which has probably one--.
>>Ian: Oh, yeah.
Let's bring that up.
This is, yeah.
>>Dan: Actually, I don't know about, the problem
is is that you don't see the feature graphic
on the tablet.
I guess I could go into Chrome.
>>Ian: You do, don't you?
>>Dan: No.
No, it doesn't show up.
That's the problem.
>>Ian: Oh.
We'll go into Chrome then.
>>Dan: We're going into Chrome.
Let's see.
[Dan sings]
All right.
While I'm going into Chrome, let's cut to
something else.
But however this game is, this game is really
fun.
And I thought I had Chrome on here.
Do I not actually have Chrome on here?
>>Ian: There's a browser, I think.
>>Dan: I know.
I know.
All right.
Well, let's go to play dot Google dot com.
>>Ian: Dan is now using the keyboard.
>>Dan: Yes.
That's good.
You can be the voice of Dan.
Dan is now using this amazing attachment,
which someone said was totally irrelevant
on tablets, but is actually quite useful.
So, [coughs].
>>Ian: Nice.
Perfect.
OK.
>>Dan: This is the, all right.
Now we're pointing at the camera.
Now, let's go to Nosferatu.
Now, I can't guarantee.
Nose candy free.
That was kind of awesome.
>>Ian: Nose candy?
>>Dan: It's what it said.
That must be a game.
So here we are.
Nosferatu, Run from the Sun.
So, yeah.
So, to look at this game.
That was the feature [inaudible].
Now, I do love the inclusion of the Google
Play logo as if we didn't already know we
weren't already on Google Play.
>>Ian: That's a serious issue.
Not because we don't love Google Play because
of course we do.
And props to you guys for representing.
But it doesn't belong in your feature graphic
because we can't actually put this on the
feature page.
We'd look silly.
>>Dan: Yeah, yeah.
So, the second thing is obviously, your text
is really, really small.
No one's gonna really be able to read that
if it actually does get featured.
>>Ian: Yeah.
The important thing is you take this, you
back up about 20, 25 feet from your average
size monitor and if you can still read your
text, boom.
You're good.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: Because the thing is, we will shrink
that down until it's about an inch wide.
And that's an inch wide being held probably
about 18 inches away from someone's face on
a phone.
And you've got to have some pretty good eyes
to read "Run from the Sun" off of that graphic
when it's that size.
>>Dan: Yeah.
I mean, "Run from the Sun" is useful because
it actually tells you what the game is, which
is a runner.
So, let's go back to the game itself.
>>Ian: Well, and it distinguishes you from
all the other Nosferatu titles out there.
>>Dan: Yes.
Right.
>>Ian: I'm not sure we have enough.
We need some more--.
So, this is a one control endless runner.
>>Dan: It is.
[coughs] Yes.
It actually, I think, might eventually get
more than one control, but initially that's
your goal is your one control.
And you basically, you can do different kinds
of jumps.
>>Ian: Yeah, nice.
Are your ears actually acting as wings in
this case, or?
>>Dan: Well, I should say that there is, so
what is interesting is that there actually
are two modes to this game.
There is running and flying.
And--.
>>Ian: Wait.
Did you just eat that girl?
>>Dan: I think so.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: I'm not positive.
Oh, I completed my daily mission.
I'm sure I get some bonus for that.
No.
And I've fallen and then I get fried by the
sun.
>>Ian: It's really pretty though.
I love the graphics on this.
I think it's really, really cute.
>>Dan: Yeah, it's really well done.
I mean, I was really pleased with this.
I actually played with the game a lot.
There isn't anything that I found that was
wrong other than again, like in this particular
case, the back key doesn't do anything.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Bad.
>>Dan: But for the most part, that's the biggest
problem with the game.
>>Ian: By the way, so let me just take one
moment.
I wanna pimp our Google+ presentation, or
Google I/O presentation.
>>Dan: OK, yeah.
>>Ian: We did a presentation called "Ten Things
Every Game Developer Should Know."
And it was fun.
>>Dan: And it was funny.
I was half asleep when I was presenting it.
>>Ian: We wanted to do another take.
OK, so we weren't super happy with the video
team on it.
It was streamed live.
Or no, it wasn't streamed live.
It was recorded live.
There's a few slides that were super funny
that didn't make it on there.
But the important thing is, there's a lot
of really good information there.
And it's not unentertaining.
>>Dan: And you get to see what we look like
when we're wearing ugly cyan shirts.
>>Ian: Exactly.
And when I'm not wearing my girdle, which
apparently you were that day as I recall.
>>Dan: [laughs] I was wearing your girdle?
I didn't know that.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Thanks a lot.
Never share a hotel room with this guy.
Your clothes will disappear and not the good
clothes.
Here's the thing.
There are a small number of things that a
lot of game developers get wrong.
We mention it on the show here, but the important
thing is if you get these things wrong, you
won't get featured on Google Play.
And if you do them right, your chances of
getting featured rise astronomically because
if you do them right the first time, you get
to go to the front of the line.
Whereas all the people that got them wrong
go to the back of the line till they get retested.
>>Dan: So basically, if you do something wrong,
even if people like your game, someone has
to go, "You did something wrong in your game."
Is it actually worth spending the time to
contact you?
Is your game good enough that it's worth fixing?
While if you get everything right, then the
only question is, is it good enough to get
on the featured list on some day when, perhaps,
there aren't many things in the queue.
Then, your chances of getting featured are
much higher.
So, definitely these are really important
things we're talking about.
In this case, the back key is actually the
biggest problem with the game.
I actually didn't see any other issues with
this game other than that key doesn't play
music on the lock screen.
The game is fun.
The feature graphic does need to change if
we were gonna feature it.
There's no question about that.
But the game is cool.
And I would say yeah.
Make some of those changes.
Let us know.
I hope you've been watching and we'll watch.
>>Ian: Yeah, we do like the game.
Great work.
>>Dan: Definitely like the game.
>>Ian: All right.
>>Dan: All right.
So, next game.
Fish Farm.
>>Ian: Woohoo.
>>Dan: Now, Fish Farm is what you guys have
been watching on the background if you've
been watching what's going on it.
And I would say the other thing, you can't
really see from here that the tank is slightly
lower resolution than I want it to be.
There's a little bit of artifacting.
You can tell that it's compressed.
But for the most part, it looks pretty good.
And--.
>>Ian: No, no.
Hang on.
[pause]
>>Dan: It's very a scientific study.
>>Ian: Hard to tell.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It's a little blurry.
And you can see here up in the corner, you
can see actually some very nice artifacting
from of the background.
But other than that, it's pretty good.
My feeling is if you're gonna have one screen
of your game that is as important as this
one, in this particular case, it may make
sense to upgrade the quality just a little
bit of that one image.
So, but what I do like about the game is that
it has 3D fish, which is so cool.
It's very, the fish are actually modeled and
you can see they can spin in any direction.
And they do have behaviors.
You can do stuff like, I wanna.
So, first of all, this is the way the menus
work, by the way, is I tap here.
There's this little plus sign that brings
up the actual menu.
And then you can do things like feed the fish.
All of my fish are mostly full, but you can
see that I can give them food.
And the ones that aren't still hungry--.
>>Ian: See, they've got like, RTS-style meters
over them to tell them how much they've been
fed.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: This makes me want to shoot them.
>>Dan: And the free--.
>>Ian: I wanna send my marines out and see
if I can eat them.
>>Dan: So, the food, the thing about the food
is that I'm giving them cheap food.
This food only lasts for eight hours.
You can also get more expensive food that
will last longer.
And some of it requires slow currency, or
real money.
And some of it can be purchased with in-game
currency.
>>Ian: Slow currency.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: Right.
The type that takes a long time to earn.
>>Dan: Or that you cannot earn.
>>Ian: Unless, of course, you're Dan or Reto.
>>Dan: [laughs]
>>Ian: You pretty much earn it very quickly.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, or unless you just spend a dollar or two
on the game.
But--.
>>Ian: OK.
Sorry, I'm no good at spit takes.
We really need to get Alex back.
>>Dan: We do.
We do.
The spit take when he was drinking the beer
that had gone through a cat's gut was pretty
amazing.
>>Ian: And I wish we'd had him on video.
Last week, I served Dan the one thousand IBU
Mikkeller beer, which was quite bitter.
Not impossibly bitter, but pretty damn bitter.
No reaction.
I was extremely disappointed.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Well, I--.
>>Ian: I wanted to find another co-star at
that point.
>>Dan: The problem is, is that I've been working
with Ian for a while and I've spent the last
six months building up a resistance to bitter
before the game.
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Dan: And before I got to try this one.
So, it really didn't mean much.
I'm like, "Oh, bitter.
I'm used to it."
>>Ian: Pretty much.
But--.
>>Dan: We drink a lot of IPAs.
>>Ian: But when we fed that to Alex, oh my
God.
It was like a Keystone ad.
>>Dan: Yeah, that's because Alex shares his
cube with me.
So, really he's not used to bitter.
>>Ian: Don't we actually all share a cube?
>>Dan: We do actually.
>>Ian: Isn't Alex bitter all the time about
your, you know?
>>Dan: So true.
>>Ian: Habits.
Yeah.
>>Dan: So, in any case, but I'm not bitter.
He's the one who's bitter, you see?
>>Ian: Good point.
OK.
>>Dan: So, why would I be bitter?
>>Ian: Can we get anyone, anything other than
these blue fish, though?
I mean, these--.
>>Dan: No, these are the starter fish.
Now, if I want to--.
>>Ian: Can we get a red fish?
>>Dan: I'll show you.
So, we can go "edit" "fish," first of all.
And I select a fish here.
And I can make it bigger.
>>Ian: Wait.
You can just make the fish bigger?
What kind of a bizarre eugenics program are
you running?
>>Dan: Well, no, no, no.
You see, like, the problem is it takes a while.
So, I can rename it.
I can move it.
I can breed it or sell it.
There's really not much I can do.
>>Ian: Nice.
Is that Japanese below?
>>Dan: I don't know.
And then, but I can go to the store and that
will say one.
And if I go to the store, you'll see that
I can buy this fish.
Or for slow currency, I can get another boring
fish.
So, until we get much farther up the list
here with experience points and in-game currency,
I can't buy most of the cool fish.
Now, this is one of the things I noted about
the game is this is a really, really slow,
slow scrolling thing.
>>Ian: Wait now.
What is going on there?
>>Dan: I don't know.
This is running out of Transformer Prime.
>>Ian: OK, yeah.
You're running on a very fast machine and
you're getting terrible scroll performance.
Now, given this is ICS and not Jellybean,
but still.
>>Dan: Yeah, no, no, no.
This is, something bad's going here.
I'm pretty sure the entire background is being
drawn as this thing is going.
So, first of all, what I would do is given
that this takes up almost the full screen,
pause the screen behind it.
There's no reason to have that continuing
to draw.
>>Ian: Right, right, right.
Now, they don't have that alpha-d out either,
right?
I mean, it's a--.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It's--.
>>Ian: Yeah.
I would say for the couple millimeters of
aquarium we've got on the side there, totally
not worth it.
>>Dan: Yeah.
No.
>>Ian: Let's maybe just make that a full screen.
>>Dan: Or just pause it behind it.
It doesn't even have to draw.
It's so sad watching that thing scroll.
So, that is one of the important things that
I noticed.
But you can buy decor.
You can get change the size of your tank,
which allows you to, you can also buy new
tanks.
So, there's a lot of stuff you can do.
And it's split between currency that is again,
slow currency, as well as currency that you
can get in the game.
>>Ian: Let's buy a fish.
Let's buy a cool fish.
>>Dan: I don't have any cool, there's only
one other fish.
>>Ian: Buy a cool fish.
What?
>>Dan: I don't have enough experience points
to buy a cool fish.
>>Ian: I'll give you some money.
>>Dan: I can't.
I have to actually get experience points.
You have to play the game.
>>Ian: You can't even just use money?
I can't go in here and say, just plop down,
"Look.
I got a hundred bucks."
I mean, "Google has a hundred bucks.
Actually, my buddy Ian Armstrong, he has a
hundred bucks on his Google card and we're
just gonna buy a great fish."
Can I do that?
>>Dan: Not that I know of.
I think you have to actually get experience.
>>Ian: You know what?
I like that actually.
That's cool.
You actually have to play the game.
It's not just about how much money you have.
So, kudos.
>>Dan: You have to play it.
I also think, yeah, exactly.
So, in any case, in fact, these fish I think
are already bigger than when I first purchased
them.
I'll purchase a new one just so you can see
what a new fish would look like 'cause--.
>>Ian: Can we at least get that gold-tail
thing?
>>Dan: Well, I wanted to purchase one of these
guys here.
>>Ian: Oh, OK.
Oh, is it the little tiny one there?
>>Dan: Yeah.
See that one's smaller?
So, they do actually get bigger.
>>Ian: You're an excellent fish keeper.
>>Dan: Thank you.
Yes, you can see my fish are all relatively
happy.
That being said I should feed this new guy
'cause--.
>>Ian: You're better to the fish than you
are to me.
>>Dan: Hey.
>>Ian: Dan's a gardener, by the way.
He's one of those guys that brings produce
in and you're like, "Awesome."
>>Dan: It's good.
Today I brought tomatoes in.
>>Reto: I haven't received any of this produce.
>>Ian: Really?
You didn't get any of his cape gooseberries?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: You know, the French enjoy cape gooseberries.
Apparently.
>>Dan: So, they're, anyways.
I brought tomatoes.
They're in the micro-kitchen today.
So, enjoy.
>>Ian: You put them in the micro-kitchen?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: What?
You didn't give us first dibs on those?
>>Dan: No.
I just put them in the micro-kitchen.
So.
>>Ian: But everybody goes into the micro-kitchen,
even people that we hate.
>>Dan: Well, yeah.
So, anyways.
That's, so, but this game does a lot of things
right.
And one of them is it actually has a great
list of settings here, which also is very
slow to scroll.
>>Ian: Right.
But that's not a great list of settings because
it doesn't use the settings.
>>Dan: It doesn't use the settings.
For a game, it's better.
>>Ian: It's true.
We do give you a pass on your game if you're
trying to fit into something, but the truth
is I'm not buying it here.
>>Dan: No.
Well, they're using standard controls.
But the other thing is they're not using common
theme.
They've got the menu of shame.
They've got the zoom control of shame.
In fact, let's see if, does it die.
Hold on.
>>Ian: This doesn't feel like a game settings
menu.
This doesn't say, "Hey, I did something different
from normal settings because I had a cool
artistic vision."
>>Dan: I have it stretched to fill the screen.
>>Ian: This is saying, "I did something--."
What?
>>Dan: It's so much faster if I have it stretched
to fill the screen at low res.
>>Ian: [whistles] Well, yeah.
That does sort of make sense, right?
>>Dan: Yeah, of course.
I just, I actually, but good.
Kudos on their part.
They actually change correctly and they don't
crash, which really is--.
>>Ian: That is good, but they probably shouldn't
have the button of shame.
>>Dan: No, they shouldn't have the button
of shame.
>>Ian: That's a pointing compatibility button
>>Dan: It's running out there.
The menu of shame and a button of shame.
>>Ian: But so, just to clarify what I was
talking about.
So, obviously, we have design guidelines in
Android.
We have things that we want you to follow.
And that applies to most apps and many things
that aren't just normal apps.
>>Dan: And mostly, we actually have write
guidelines now.
And that's really awesome.
Now for games, we usually give them a pass
'cause usually games are trying to do their
own thing.
They're trying to like, have this really cool
custom look.
This is not cool, custom look.
You'd be better off using our guidelines.
There's a whole bunch of Android controls
sitting here.
>>Ian: This goes for apps as well.
Like, if you have a very cool custom look
of some kind, and we don't really care what
it is, but if you've got some sort of art
direction where you're saying, "Look, we have
our own special look."
Now, one thing that we don't buy is when people
say, "We have our own special look," and then
we boot it up and it looks like somebody else's
phone OS, we're not buying that.
>>Dan: Yeah.
What's up with that?
>>Ian: But you've got your own special artistic
vision?
Of course.
Do that.
We love that, but if you're not bringing anything
to the table, how about just using our normal
controls, because people like that?
>>Dan: Well, these are normal controls, but
one, these--.
>>Ian: I'm sorry.
Well, in this case, these are normal settings.
>>Dan: Normal settings.
Well, I would say--.
>>Ian: We don't have any normal controls that
have that gradient.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Part of the problem with these--.
>>Ian: No.
I'm sorry.
That gradient, I'm, no.
>>Dan: Part of the problem with these controls
is that there are, if you look at it, they
are, as you know, as you can see, the Gingerbread
version of the controls.
And it would be so much nicer--.
>>Ian: Did we ever ship that gradient?
>>Dan: No.
>>Ian: That's what I thought.
>>Dan: But these controls, the on and of--
>>Ian: Even when we were shipping really bad
UI, we never went that far.
>>Dan: Yeah.
So, anyways.
So it would be nice to actually see these
things themed with the theme of the device
and that's very easy to fix.
And if you target SVK Version 14, it'll just
boom, happen automatically.
So, that's one thing I'd love to see this
game do is make all the buttons of shame go
away.
It would probably make this look a little
bit better.
Even better is just use a standard settings
pane if you're gonna make it this much like
the RR stuff, but not quite.
>>Ian: It'll save a ton of time.
It's really, I mean, did you just have an
intern that needed work or what?
Come on.
>>Dan: This, anyways.
>>Ian: OK.
Now I'm being mean.
I apologize.
But part of the reason I can be mean here
is because you guys have a great aquarium.
It really looks nice.
>>Dan: Yeah.
We like it.
One thing I would just like to see is when
you're actually on live wallpaper, there's
really not much feeling that I'm swiping between
screens.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: It'd be cool if it actually did something.
You're already gearing--.
>>Ian: If you could move the camera just slightly,
that would be awesome.
>>Dan: Yeah.
You're already rendering things kind of in
3D, and I know you have this cool like, this
edge of the glass effect blur thing going
there, but actually, honestly, I'd much rather
see the screen just move a couple of pixels
as you did that just to make you feel like
it was doing something.
>>Ian: It would be more typical of live wallpaper.
>>Dan: So, that would be my only complaint
of the live wallpaper.
Other than that, it's really cool.
It actually looks like an aquarium.
I kind of wanna keep it around.
Maybe it'll stay around for a few weeks on
this machine.
>>Ian: Oh yeah, absolutely.
>>Dan: Unless someone else comes up with--.
So, one more game to look at.
>>Ian: No, no, no.
Hang on.
What happens if you like, tap the back of
the screen right now?
So that's one other thing that you can do
with live wallpaper.
>>Dan: I want the fish to react, man.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Yeah.
Make the fish react.
Get your taps to actually do something.
Maybe it takes you into the game.
Maybe you tap on a fish and it says, "Do you
wanna feed it?"
I mean, live wallpapers are very, very powerful.
You can put pretty much anything you want
in it.
And why not use it to drive a little bit more
user engagement?
Of course, you don't want to go overboard,
but hey, why not a little bit?
>>Dan: Exactly.
Yep.
Sounds good to me.
All right.
Final game is Crates on Deck.
And this game has a distinct visual style,
which is fun.
Although this title screen is kind of cheeseball.
>>Ian: Can we just take the keyboard off,
'cause damn, that looks kinda dumb?
>>Dan: Yeah, I know.
But we're only showing the HDMI.
For right now, that's working--.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
Go back to the screen.
>>Ian: Oh no.
No.
Shame him, Reto.
>>Dan: So, Crates on Deck is a game that is
in the landscape of mode by default.
Play Gravity Galleon, which is the first series
of levels.
And so it's cool and it tells you which, you
start off with that side up and you'll see
why that's important because rotating the
screen actually does change the physics.
It does change.
So, we rotate the screen to the side.
Now what we have to do is drag our crates
over to get that.
>>Ian: So, you just change the gravity.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: But the ocean is still in the same
place.
>>Dan: That's right.
That's just a backdrop.
So, the problem is--.
>>Ian: Just saying the world doesn't make
sense.
>>Dan: The world doesn't make sense.
>>Ian: Also, this game doesn't make sense
is what I'm saying.
>>Dan: Oh, well that might be true.
But the world definitely doesn't make sense.
All you have to do is see what happened in
a movie theater this week and you realize
the world doesn't make sense.
>>Ian: Too soon.
>>Dan: Too soon?
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: I don't, I really, I think it's clear
that doesn't make sense.
All right.
So now we can do, is we can drag these over
and of course, I did that completely wrong
'cause yeah.
So, actually it sucks.
Actually, this is, I don't know how to solve
this puzzle.
>>Ian: I don't understand what we're--.
Oh, you need to get the red crate onto the
X?
>>Dan: Right.
Yeah.
See, if I drag one underneath it, physics
doesn't actually work.
They don't drag together.
So I can drag it like that.
>>Ian: Well, maybe they're just frictionless
crates.
>>Dan: They are frictionless crates.
So I've gotta get it all the way over there.
So what I need to do is actually move, go
like that.
I think I like this.
Thinking outside of the box.
So, that's the way the game actually works.
And each one is a little puzzle.
And I think it's really fun.
I think it's a really fun game.
>>Ian: It's not bad.
>>Dan: And it's fun where you have to deal
with two things, rotating the screen and moving
boxes.
Oh, sorry.
We lost HDMI again.
the whole reason we're having this plugged
into the keyboard and looking lame, as you
can see, there we are, is so that I wouldn't
pull out the HDMI too terribly as I rotated
the screen.
>>Ian: It didn't help all that much, but OK.
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly.
It really doesn't.
>>Ian: Yeah, we need to have like, I would
love to have an HDMI connecter that works
like a BNC connecter.
>>Dan: Yeah.
I would, too.
These, all of these frictionless connecters
are just--.
>>Ian: So, everything that you're doing here
seems to be oriented around 90 degree rotations.
Is that--
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: do you actually rotate it in different
ways?
>>Dan: No, just 90 degree rotations.
So--.
>>Ian: I don't know how I feel about it.
I feel like, "Wow.
You're making me rotate my device, but--."
>>Dan: Which normally is not this painful
on most devices.
>>Ian: Well, but, you know, still.
I mean, I feel like a little bit of an idiot.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Well, only if you've got this keyboard attached
to it like I do.
I mean, realistically--.
>>Ian: I don't know.
I mean, I have to say I'm a big fan of things
that take advantage of device rotation when
it's a relatively small rotation.
I think driving games, for instance, are,
make a lot of sense.
Other ones, like I remember one of my favorite
games, Bag It, you rotate the device around
a little bit, just shake your bag, just make
all the contents settle.
But when it's rotating fully all the way around,
I don't know.
It's a little bit tough because to tell the
truth, I actually played a lot of games with
the power plugged in.
'Cause I'll sit in bed at night and I'm charging
my device and I wanna play a game or read
some news or something and so, I've got a
cable on it.
And it kinda gets in the way if I'm doing
something like this.
>>Dan: Yeah.
I like it.
I mean, I think that this is the kind of game
you play in a train.
I don't think it's the kind of game you sit
in bed and necessarily play.
It's really--.
>>Ian: It's not a bed game.
>>Dan: It's not a bed game.
This is a puzzle game.
>>Ian: A train game.
>>Dan: It's like, each, you want to solve
each puzzle in a reasonably small amount of
time and make the fewest number of moves and
rotations to do that.
And anyways, I think it's a clever game.
I think they're presentation is cool.
I would like to see them, even though I think
that this is cool, I think that their Crates
on Deck could look a little bit, the title
screen here, could look a little--.
>>Ian: Let's just show that on the screen
actually.
I don't know.
I mean, let me get a closer look here.
>>Dan: You've got the shades on.
>>Ian: That just makes things better.
>>Dan: It's true.
>>Ian: Well, OK.
I mean, this is not, I think that this game--.
>>Dan: It has a distinct artistic style.
>>Ian: Right.
It's not like, the most professional artistic
style, but that may be intentional.
>>Dan: I'm sure that it is intentional.
I actually mostly wish the logo was a little
bigger.
>>Ian: I'm not sure.
I'm not sure because you got all this stuff
that's a little bit playful and then you got
drop shadows.
And I asked myself, "What professional designer
would've said, 'You know what?
Crates on Deck needs a drop shadow.'"
I would've done that.
>>Dan: It's true.
>>Ian: I would've totally put a drop shadow
there, but I'm not a professional designer.
>>Dan: Yeah, yeah.
Also, just having buttons that don't actually
react.
>>Ian: You have a button that doesn't do anything?
>>Dan: I guess it does do something.
I just didn't, I couldn't tell.
It's just turning subtle colors.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Dan: So, it is.
But yeah.
>>Ian: So there's a little bit of polish that
probably could be done.
>>Dan: So, is there anything else we wanna
talk about, other than making sure that people
know, if you didn't tune into the beginning,
that we're gonna be changing the format of
this show.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: So, if--.
>>Ian: Well, not the format exactly.
>>Dan: Well, not the format.
>>Ian: But we're still gonna drink beer, even
though I'm paying for it now and Dan isn't.
>>Dan: That's right.
And that's the way we like things.
And also, so most importantly, we're gonna
be nominating different categories of games.
So, next week is going to be tower defense
games.
Week after that are driving games.
And week after that are J and KRPGs.
>>Ian: And you can vote for these now.
You can vote for them all the way up to the
Wednesday before the day they get reviewed.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: And what you should do is we would
prefer that the developer of the game nominate
the game and we would, we definitely encourage
you to add a Google+ link to link to your
own Google+ profile.
Don't just put your Google+ name because a
lot of those names are duplicates.
We don't know necessarily who you are.
If you get the URL of your Google+ profile
and put it in there, then we'll be able to
find you and we'll let you know if your game
is being reviewed or not.
And hopefully, get you on air with us live
and have a bunch of fun with you.
Anyway, that didn't come out right.
But the other thing that we want, though,
and this is quite important, is please do
make sure that you have the Play store link
in your title.
Don't make us guess what it is.
Just link to it in the Play store, link to
your Google+ profile, and then, anyone that
likes it please vote it up.
If you don't like it, vote it down.
Either way, our moderator page does allow
you to leave comments and we'd really, really
appreciate it if you could leave comments
saying why you do or don't like each particular
game.
>>Dan: Yeah.
It's enough to say, "This guy is not my friend."
At least that explains your one-star vote.
And so, but at least put that in there.
>>Reto: So, I was listening to the beginning
of the show and there was some pretty funky
tunes playing over the title screen.
Who picked them?
>>Dan: Very good point.
>>Ian: That was actually a song that I wrote
back when I had time to do such things.
It's called "Lithium."
And you can't get it anywhere, but maybe I'll
put it online.
>>Dan: Exactly.
So, you'll at least get to hear a little bit
of it.
If you wanna hear it again, of course you
can replay this when the live stream goes,
when the archive stream goes up.
And so yeah.
That's another episode the Friday Review of
Games.
>>Ian: Thanks for joining us.
We will be back next week when we review tower
defense games.
Please visit our moderator and let us know
what you think we should review.
Go ahead and leave comments on the YouTube
stream.
When we decide that we're good and drunk and
we wanna hate ourselves some, we will totally
read them.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: Either way, we'll see you next week.
Thanks a lot.